so chris brockman yes sir uh if you look
through
14 weeks okay in the national football
league and i know that there's still two
games but nobody
in tonight's game is uh remotely close
and the radar screen
will be at the top five in this category
uh
leaders in receiving yards in the nfl
for 14 weeks oh it's travis kelsey no
can i set it up well you asked me a
question i'm saying
i looked at it oh i thought you said
number five is deandre hopkins
oh sorry number five number four tyree
kell
yes number three
number three is stefan diggs who had a
great night last night
number two is dk metcalf yeah that's
true number one's a tight end chris
travis kelsey now stop it
guys are idiots i'm trying to give this
man his due he's also
the the walter payton man of the year
nominee from the kansas city chiefs your
defending super
bowl champs fresh off the big win in
miami he is travis kelsey back here on
the show how are you travis
rich fellas always a pleasure to be on
yeah
it's a pleasure to have you i heard your
nickname big red the burgermeister
man i'll tell you what that that might
be as good as it gets right there
he is he's the bird he's the burger
don't forget crazy he's a crazy burger
meister man he is just
it's all good crazy though good crazy
uh uh you know and you know i'm sitting
here
you know as you know i've been fortunate
to watch a lot of football talk a lot of
ball in my
my days i just have not really seen a
quarterback
throw off his back foot from his own
goal line and find his tight end
one-on-one
with some poor snook who's attempting to
cover you right around midfield
and i i've never seen it before what is
it like to actually play
in that travis what is that like
it's uh it's reaping the benefit of
working your tail off man i think uh i
think that's
everybody on on this team really is um
throughout the
throughout the week we just you know we
hack away at the fundamentals and
the scheme and uh trying to trying to
figure out a defenses
or another team schemes and you know
what uh just going out there and
players making plays man that's all i
can really say is uh
we got a lot of guys that can make plays
downfield um
and all over the field at that and uh
you know what just
that was just one example of it and so
do you remind your um
your colleague tyreek hill that you have
more receiving yards than him does that
ever come up
in a very awkward manner does that
happen no no it's uh
it's just awkward that everybody's been
talking about that specifically
um but i think i think tariq still
doesn't get enough credit for the type
of wide receiver he is i mean obviously
um we both benefit off of each other's
success
uh but more so i mean you gotta he's a
big threat right
i mean default he has the most in nfl
history i think already i think he
passed randy moss a couple weeks ago
in terms of like touchdowns 40 plus
yards
uh deep and um i mean he's the deadliest
weapon in the national football league
guitar
you saw him take a little jet sweep and
get a rushing touchdown
yesterday you just have to account for
so many different ways that he can he
can hurt you
um that it kind of opens up and frees up
guys like myself
uh demarcus robinson mikol hartman and
uh sammy watkins and then the backs are
out there doing their thing as well it's
just
it's a fun offense to play in but there
is an eye i still think uh
tyree tyree doesn't get the credit he
deserves no i know but he
there's still an eye on travis uh
between you and and
and between you and he though between
you and he though uh
who's got the 99 rating in madden talk
to me which one
man i i guess madden gave that to me
love making me talk about myself um
come on now i mean going from a 73 to a
99
over the course of seven years man it's
uh it's definitely cool to uh to have
that as an accomplishment knowing that
i'm still a kid when it comes to this
game and
uh being a fan of the game so playing
madden is
is always uh in the repertoire
all right i'll i'll i'll i'll pump you
for the figurative heisman then travis
and you could just talk about
uh other things that said um
i i you know i reached out to you when i
saw this because there is no
look everything we could talk about all
your statistical accolades
including the first tight end to have
five straight thousand yard
seasons in the history of the nfl um but
nothing gets bigger than the walter
payton man of the year award and you're
a nominee
for that congratulations and i do want
you to talk about what that means
for you travis please that is um i
appreciate that and uh
it's definitely um it's something that
uh
that you can definitely have honor honor
and pride about
um obviously i'm not in the in the
community
thinking oh this will help me win the
walter payton man of the year i just go
out and i try and influence
you know the younger generation to to
you know
try and do better for themselves and
give them advantages that they wouldn't
have otherwise
and uh just giving kids a chance and the
confidence to do what they want in life
um i feel like it's half the battle and
uh and
you know there's definitely an award and
i'm i'm
greatly honored to to represent the
kansas city chiefs organization and
the community of kansas city in this
regard because uh
you know they they the the kingdom is is
there every single sunday every single
game day and
and throughout the week you know hyping
us up and giving us all the love that we
that that we need to to go out there and
fight for them and then on top of that
i just want to you know show them as
much love and support as they give us
now when you're talking about giving
kids the you know support as well as
confidence to do what they want to do
can you just walk me through um a couple
of of things that you have been
able to affect change like that in
kansas city and how people can get
involved with what you're doing
travis yes 87running.org is the
is my foundation's website and from
there you can click away and figure out
you know everything from there but uh
i've i've been able to
team up and this isn't this hasn't just
been me obviously it's my team effort of
myself my foundation uh even my
teammates
getting in the community and uh and
raising funds for operation breakthrough
which is a
organization a school that that um
that is here for the the families that
are kind of struggling and the
kids that have a unfortunate situation
at home uh
and what it does is it gives them the
advantages that uh
you know a strong school system and a
community support system would give them
uh both educationally
and uh outside of school at home and uh
in terms of keeping everybody healthy
and uh giving them those kind of
resources and it's just been uh
it's been an absolute pleasure working
with them um
and and and seeing these kids grow from
kindergarten to eighth grade
uh we 87 are running um helped build uh
the robotics lab at the original school
and we're
right now we're trying to extend the
stem system into high school because
right now the school system or the
operation breakthrough is only
kindergarten through eighth and we just
want to make sure that
when the kids go to high school they
have somewhere to go and uh
and this is definitely going to be that
for them i mean i i i could not be more
proud to know you man
seriously i'm getting choked up just to
hear about that seriously that's fact
uh and and then you know uh i want you
to talk on wednesday's show i've got
uh laurent duvernay tardif calling in
because he's one of those
my guy larry he smokes i haven't heard
from larry in forever man i gotta give
that guy a call
right because he's he's one of the
sports persons of the year for sports
illustrated and the reason why you
haven't heard from him is because
it's literally taken us two weeks to
just even get a phone call from him
because he is
truly on the front lines battling covid
because he's dr tardif
uh in his native canada uh and i'm
wondering you know again
that's another thing to talk about you
could talk about the football aspect
that he's not there
you know to help uh with this season but
he's amazing man
i mean what what should i know about him
before he's a real life hero man
it everything you read about him is
exactly who he is he cares about people
and uh and to the to the extent of you
know some of the things that he wanted
to do
in his football career got pushed back
because of how much he thinks
uh or how much he he believes he can
help people and
and i mean i love him for it and more
power to him i can't
i can't wait to see him back in the
office and uh and rocking the chief's
uniform and digging people out in the
run game but
right now he's uh he's using the the
gentle giant hands
he has to uh to heal people and it's a
beautiful thing
that's for sure i believe he's up in
montreal doing it all yep he is and
uh yeah he is uh before i let you go a
couple items first things first um
your brother we noticed that you've gone
high and tight travis
seems like you've just gone the actual
cleanup route you've cleaned up i mean
there's no
doesn't seem like it's high and tight
with the hair and the facial hair and
all that stuff
um your brother's gone in the exact
opposite direction
and uh i'm wondering what you think
we've got a photograph of that up here
right now
uh travis oh yeah what's up oh yeah no i
saw i saw him walking in on game day i
saw the
short video that the eagles posted man
and i'll tell you what when jason kelsey
has got the mullet flowing
and he's got the timberlands on is
something's about to go down
i mean that is like that's an action
movie him walking into the last scene of
an action movie right that's that's it
right there
and you don't want to get in jason
kelsey's way when he when he has that
when he has that look going
uh i've seen him one too many times yeah
man and look and hertz is starting and
they come up with a win and he's got
he's got the the mullet flowing and
oh yeah so guys zack gertz got me it
hurts to hurt baby
that's right there's there's a little
rain to it that's right and so you don't
have that
i mean um you don't have that desire to
go full
flowing like that or you know you just
tell you what it just doesn't it doesn't
flow the same
it doesn't mean he's got he's got that
mane over there that's just
i mean i i can't imitate it you know i
just gotta i gotta
work with what i got rich and that's the
high and tight fade man
and the 99 rating and the most receiving
yards out of everybody who catches balls
in the national football league in 2020
and mahomes
and all of it going on right now i do
have to ask this question now
travis okay and this is a big setup and
seriously
you do realize what your career path is
on right now i mean what you've done
you've done things people haven't done
and you've added the off the field stuff
too which is very crucial
when you are putting your name in front
of people for highest honors of all time
do you think that at all literally at
any moment point in time
that what career path you're on travis
it's uh the really the only time i
really think about it is when family
brings it up
and uh to see how proud i make my my mom
and my dad and
the people around me you know that's uh
that's what it's really for
and uh i just go to work every single
day man i enjoy coming in to work with
the guys in the building
and uh this journey has been
unbelievable up to this point
but i still got a lot of motivation to
to make it even better than what it has
been and uh
that's both on and off the field so
we're gonna keep hacking away at a rich
but it's uh it's definitely been a
blessing
and i'm extremely grateful for my
situation so far you know certainly i
mean you know
you're you're an ohio guy and that's you
know where it all winds up i'm serious
man
this is you you're you uh and you got
the quarterback signed and you got the
coach signed
and you got it all you got to all work
like nobody's leaving
it's not like anybody's leaving you've
got this thing why they got the table
wired
travis essentially it sure it sure feels
like this man especially when uh
everybody's
in the in this building has the
motivation to keep you know getting
better
it's just it's an awesome feeling i'll
tell you and uh
i'll let the i'll let the road you know
take care of itself i'll just keep
coming into work every single day
and they got the again the burgermeister
is that what he seriously
is he do me a favor i'm i'm desperate to
get a nickname to stick
um please help on that front okay start
referring
start referring he treats us to a burger
every saturday night what do you mean
what are you talking about he'll
literally treat us to it after the team
meeting the night before the games he'll
say
i'll treat you to a cheeseburger right
after this and then the cheeseburgers
arrive
literally oh yeah the cheeseburgers are
there sometimes they're grass-fed
sometimes where you know
we're west coast and it's a little
different and you know but when usually
when we're around kansas city you get
those big nice
you know meaty burgers man okay they
they they vary depending on where you
are in the states
okay and where you're playing because
big red meister man he always has them
for you
right big red is so old school let's
start calling please go ahead call him
burgermeister let's see if it sticks
let's do it
let's do it i'll call it to him to his
face and see
how his reaction is and then i'll let
you know whether it's a no-go for me
i'll pick oh okay i'll take the hint
we'll see how it goes thanks for the
call travis really appreciate it you
keep falling out congrats again on the
the walter payton
uh nomination that is just amazing just
been great and the one season thank you
brother and the one
seed too congrats on that and and uh and
everything on to that thing
you got it you take care of yourself
travis thanks for the call hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here